you're watching mailing it in
all right welcome to mailing it in
you're right I read and then we go
camping
in hell here we go
Frenchie asks oh I'm gonna go to cat
first on this one what is one secret you
kept to yourself since childhood that
you don't mind sharing now
oh yeah you come on it's childhood yes I
don't know I can't think of one come on
uh one time I peed on the floor for
attention
I knew there was something but I was
like not old I was like three but I knew
better yeah that's a pretty good memory
Tyrus
stuff my brother in the dryer
watched him go like that
only agreed to let him out if you
promise not to tell
that's good good persuasion yeah yeah I
um I'll I'll throw in one for I uh I use
my dad's uh coin collection to buy the
first Van Halen album
a good one I know pretty bad huh but
look at it this way it's 1979 or 78 so
it was only four dollars
or uh 16 quarters
really expensive quarters Molly yeah I
did a lot of bad things as a kid but my
parents were like
uh like amateur detectives or something
they figured out everything there was no
secret I could keep and they will vouch
for that so I I don't have any but only
because my parents are authoritarian
tyrants
so the secret was you were raised by
wolves all right hotep I went through uh
an identity crisis freshman year to
senior year freshman year I thought I
was Tupac senior year I thought I was
Zach Morris off of Saved by the Bell
so imagine me freshman year coming to
school with like these Rags tied on my
head with like baggy jeans to senior
year dressing like a preppy white dude
it was terrible you know Jesse waters
went through that same phase
all right here's a good one with
commencement season in high gear wow so
well written what is one piece of advice
you'd offer if you were invited to
address a group of graduates I'll go
back to you hotep since you were last a
piece of advice if you were to address a
group of grads during commencement
season oh man it's a lot we can see here
first of all you wasted your money
that's number one
number two
um hopefully you didn't become a liberal
or socialist while you were here and if
you did then maybe you need to rip up
your degree
that's very strong
what about you Molly you probably have
done I have you've done commencement
addresses and I don't think I said what
I'm thinking now which is just don't
focus on failure if you've messed up or
if something if someone's done something
bad to you just move on and keep going
that's good that's basically don't
become don't adopt a victim mindset
exactly which is becoming a huge problem
even when things aren't happening that
are bad for people they still see
themselves as victims all right uh Tyrus
advice pay your bill
[Applause]
that's it yeah that's it pay your bills
yeah then everything flows from there
Kat any advice for the grads
uh a lot fewer people are gonna care
about you so so buckle up and focus on
yourself that's interesting yeah focus
on yourself yeah yeah you have to and
you're young it's like you get you
you're in high school in college you
have all these friends none of those
people are giving about you in 10 years
wow that's true it's true it's true you
guys all hanging out with your high
school friends after this didn't think
so
next question who told you something
that you really didn't want to hear or
even fired you when you were young but
now you realize they were right
um
Molly I have been fired I think getting
fired is a good experience that people
should go through it always ends up
being something better after it happens
there's not a an invitation to any of my
employers right now
um but I can't say that I thought they
were right I just it helped me redirect
my energies get into different lines of
work I guess that is a form of people
I've been fired three times so yeah I
think I think it's true usually the
firing is directed at you because you're
better than they are that's what I
learned I agree completely better than
they are too big for this place I gotta
get out of here you're fired I knew it
Tyrus something that was told you that
you really didn't want to hear or even
fired you when you were young um
honestly people's feelings I cannot
stand when when someone comes up to you
and you're like hey how you living I
always say maintain it yeah Status Quo
I'm good and I don't ask well let me
tell you what happened to me I'm like
damn why
I gave you a one word answer
and then I got to sit down and hear this
long ass story about their feelings and
you have to understand and don't let it
be a woman
because then I gotta have the whole
pre-story the back story to how she was
feeling then interpreting how the other
person was feeling then throws in the
conspiracy theory and then checks to see
if I'm paying attention by asking me a
question that she first asked me in the
first five minutes you know what's
hilarious I was trying to figure out how
you were answering this question you
were asking who told you something that
you really didn't want to hear yeah
but then but you left out the part but
then you realized they were right you
left that part off I never pay attention
they could be right
I have no idea it was like where does he
get the part where they I start looking
up
[Laughter]
it's amazing
oh all right well you know cat did I go
to you yet
yes answer the uh just anytime my mom
told me any of the guys I was dating
were what they were a loser they were
right on that I don't understand she's
like I do
all right hotep
um well I uh one time I worked at
Walgreens and got fired for stealing
that didn't happen that didn't happen I
never worked at Walgreens
um
I worked at um Olive Garden Fridays and
I had a boss both bosses said the same
thing to me it's like you know you're
like a genius you don't belong here like
why are you working here
and I got fired from both of Joe's jobs
um real quick story my first job was at
Burger King and the guy calls me up and
he says yo I need you to come in and I'm
like today's my day off and he's like
but I need you to come in and I'm like
all right screw it I'll come in I come
in he said you can leave it too two
comes around he says you gotta leave it
three three comes around I'm like I'm
out of here he says no you're not I said
Jose you can take this shirt and I threw
it at him and I left and they got fired
on my day off
that's the blackest thing a black man
can do
I'll raise you one because I used to
work at Burger King too
oh and she got she got her fever in the
freezer and I got fired
[Applause]
it must be hard to get jungle fever in a
freezer
the temperature change okay
up next uh another easy topic a trans
man is loving the bun in his oven hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else